girl whose boyfriend wants to come in
her face
she does not want him to come in her
face but hardcore porn has taught her
that all men love coming are women's
faces all women love having their faces
come on and therefore she must let him
come on her face and she must pretend to
like it so so I am launching at Ted
today I am unveiling make love not porn
calm this is a website that hosts the
midst of hardcore porn and balances them
with the reality and it's important to
say by the way that this is absolutely
not about judgement this is not about
good and bad sex is the area of human
experience that embraces the vastest
possible range of proclivities this is
also not anti porn I'm a fan of hardcore
porn I watch it readily myself although
my overriding criteria when selecting it
has to be to find something that does
not resemble overly open heart surgery
but because the porn industry is driven
by men funded by men managed by men
directed by men and targeted at men porn
tends to present one world view porn
says this is the way it is and what I
want to say is not necessarily so please
go to make love not porn calm I want to
ask the Ted audience to do two things
be aware this is an issue because I
would never have realized that if I have
not encountered it myself and please
visit the website please see what you
think
um comment um and please pass it on
please send the link to anybody you
think would be interested and use it to
start a dialogue use it to reframe use
it to reframe an open healthy
conversation around sex in order to help
and facilitate open healthy and better
sexual relationships thank you very much
you